foreign
greatness runs in this family the famous
World Cup trophy was made in this
Workshop in Italy in 1971 by Sylvia
gotzanica
the artist beat more than 50 other
designers to be chosen to replace FIFA's
original trophy
gutz amiga's son says the current world
cup trophy design is special because it
can be photographed from all angles
giving a full world view he was also
thinking how the winner have to use it
in front of the camera and so it was
starting a way that they can really keep
in the hand and rise like a cup in a
ceremony
the cup was first awarded to what was
then West Germany in 1974. It's Made of
18 karat gold with bands of malachite on
its base depicting two humans holding up
the Earth it's nearly 37 centimeters
tall and weighs more than six kilograms
I'm trembling with anticipation to see
the trophy because I'm so excited to
work here that I can't wait to see it on
television and feel that emotion that my
colleagues have felt over the years when
they produce the World Cup
gutzaniga who died in 2016 originally
worked as a sculptor under business
owner Giorgio bortoni his firm still
holds the rights to making the iconic
Trophy and others including the UEFA
Champions League and the African Cup of
Nations
today its CEO is the granddaughter of
the man who hired gazanika many years
ago when we you love something so much
and you worked so hard to receive it you
just love it after the final game is won
the trophy comes back to Italy for a
little cosmetic touch-up before being
returned to FIFA's headquarters in
Switzerland
the winning country gets a gold-plated
replica to keep while Italy did not
qualify for the World Cup the country
will still be represented at the finals
in Qatar just in a different way they're
very emotional about the final and uh
I guess we are the only Italians that we
will be like uh crying during the final
uh match because we will know we'll be
on the podium
a family tradition elevated to Global
icon status
Leah Harding Al Jazeera